Last September, I launched a campaign at the UN in New York called HeForShe,...
...which is about men coming in support of women,...
...and women supporting men to achieve gender equality.
I want to get this conversationalist dialogue happening specifically within the fashion industry...
...to ask the leading voices about gender equality.
I have big hopes for gender equality in the fashion industry.
I think it's really improving.
I've seen some very positive steps towards equality in the industry,...
...but I think there's still a lot of racism, I think there's still a lot of sexism.
I'd really, really love to see a more diverse representation of women and men...
...in any way that makes them feel empowered.